,
WORLDWIDE, SINCE THE PANDEMIC
BEGAN.
IT IS 4.8 MILLION DEATHS.
NOW, ONE MAJOR CITY THAT IS
EMERGING FROM COVID LOCKDOWNS,
IS CERTAINLY.
FULLY VACCINATED RESIDENTS,
PUBS, GYMS, RESTAURANTS, AND
SHOPS, MORE THAN 5 MILLION
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN IN STRICT
LOCKDOWN SINCE JUNE.
BUT, OFFICIALS LIFTED MEASURES
AFTER HITTING A 70% VACCINATION
RATE, AND THE PREMIERE OF NEW
SOUTH WALES SAYS, IF EVERYONE
DOES THEIR PART, THEY CAN OPEN
UP MORE.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> TO EVERYONE ACROSS NEW SOUTH
WALES, YOU HAVE EARNED IT.
IT'S 100 DAYS OF BLOOD, SWEAT,
AND NO BEERS.
BUT, WE GOT IT, IF WE TAKE
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY, WE CAN
GET THROUGH THIS TIME.
IT IS A TIME OF OPTIMISM, IT IS
A TIME OF HOPE, AND WE KNOW
THAT BUSINESS CONFIDENCE IS
CRUCIAL AND GETTING OUR ECONOMY
THROUGH LAST YEAR.
BUT, IMPORTANTLY, WE NEED TO DO
IT IN A SAFE WAY.
>> CNN PRODUCER, ELLEN WATSON,
JOINS US LIVE FROM SYDNEY, WITH
MORE TO SEE YOU.
ANGUS, THANKS TO A SLOW START.
AUSTRALIA'S VACCINATED RATION
RATE, HIGHER THAN COUNTRIES
LIKE THE U.S., AND AFTER 4
MONTHS OF LOCKDOWNS, SYDNEY, AT
LAST, IS OPENING UP.
TALK TO US ABOUT THE REACTION
SO FAR, ACROSS THE CITY, AND
AFTER SUCH A HERCULEAN
LOCKDOWN.
>> ABSOLUTELY ROSEMARY.
PEOPLE HERE IN SYDNEY HAVE BEEN
LOCKED UP AT HOME FOR 106 DAYS
NOW, TODAY, FREEDOM DAY.
RESTAURANTS OPEN FOR A MEAL.
PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO VISIT EACH
OTHER, VISIT FRIENDS, AND
FAMILY, FOR THE FIRST TIME
SINCE JUNE.
GO TO THE GYM, GET A HAIRCUT,
AND IT IS SUCH A SENSE OF
RELIEF AROUND TOWN, AS THERE
ARE 106 DAYS, AND REALLY, HAS
SPREAD QUICKLY THROUGH THIS
CITY.
IT IS IN ONE CASE, WITH AN
UNVACCINATED DRIVER, WHICH
CAUGHT THE CORONAVIRUS FORBID
AIRLINE CREW THAT HE WAS
CHAUFFEURING, A, THAT HAS
TURNED INTO 60,000 CASES, AND
MORE, THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRETY
OF THAT OUTBREAK.
OVER 300 DEATHS AS WELL.
BUT, AS THOSE NUMBERS HAVE
INCREASED, SO HAS THE, CITY AND
THE COUNTRY'S VACCINATION
RATES.
IT HAS BEEN SPURRED ON BY THE
DANGER OF THAT DELTA VARIANT,
TO GO AND GET VACCINATED, AND
THEY HAVE SORTED OUT A LOT OF
THE SUPPLY ISSUES THAT IT HAS,
HAD THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
AND, SOME OF THE HESITANCY AS
WELL.
NOW, A RELIEF, AND A SENSE OF
CELEBRATION AROUND SYDNEY, ON
WHAT IS, ACTUALLY, A, COLD,
WINDY AND RAINY DAY.
I WAS IN A PUB EARLIER, THE
ANGIE HOTEL HERE, AND CENTRAL
SYDNEY, WHERE THEY ARE GIVING
OUT FREE BEER TO CELEBRATE THE
PUBLIC, AND TOLD US, THEY ARE
CONFIDENT ABOUT BEING ABLE TO
STAY OPEN THROUGH THE NEXT,
WEEKS AND MONTHS, AND YEARS, AS
WE LIVE WITH COVID, BECAUSE OF
AUSTRALIA'S HIGH VACCINATION
RATES.
HERE IS WHAT HE SAID.
>> I THINK WE ARE LUCKY TO GET
A HIGHER VACCINATION RATE AND
THE UK DOESN'T A MINUTE.
IT'S EXCELLENT FOR US.
WE ARE HITTING 80% NEXT WEEK,
WHICH IS QUITE GOOD.
>> THE PUB IS BETTER THAN
DRINKING IN YOUR HOUSE.
106 DAYS IN MY HOUSE?
NOTHING, COMPARED TO THE PUP.
>> SO, YOU HEARD THERE.
SOME RELIEF, SOME JOY, FROM
PEOPLE HERE IN SYDNEY.
NOW, WE ARE LOOKING TOWARDS
MILESTONES, AND HITTING 70% OF
THE ANNULLED OPERATION, WHICH
ALLOWED THESE GOING INTO, AND
IT IS HOPEFULLY, NEXT MONTH.
BUT, THEY FOUND SOME TENSION
HERE THAT THE STATES HAVE
COVID-19, IN THE COMMUNITY.
NEW SOUTH WALES, A VICTORIA
HERE, AND THE CAPITAL OF
MELBOURNE IS IN LOCKDOWN.
AND, THE FEDERAL CAPITAL OF
CANBERRA, ALSO LOCKDOWN.
THEY'RE TRYING TO GET THOSE
VACCINATION RATES TO CATCH UP
OF SYDNEY.
SOME STATES, HOWEVER, IN
AUSTRALIA, HAVE NO COVID.
THEY LIVE QUITE NORMALLY.
BUT, WITH THE BORDERS TO COVID
STATES, THEY HAVE CLOSED UP.
HOPEFULLY, AUSTRALIA CAN JOIN
UP AGAIN WITH ALL THE
VACCINATION RATES, CATCH UP,
AND OPENING UP TO THE WORLD.
ROSEMARY?